- Well, I heard that
music actually helped you
with your accent, like
breaking your accent.
'Cause I feel like that
helps me whenever I sing.
I grew up singing classical music
and it helped me take out the twang.
- Right, yeah.
- Whenever I sing,
so I can put it in and take it out.
Is that?
- Yeah, you don't really have one.
- When I talk, I do.
- When I talk, yeah.
- Especially if I'm tired or drinking.
Yes.
(audience laughs)
But really hits home then, but no,
but I heard that music actually helped you
break your accent, right?
- Yeah, I think it, I
listened to a lot of Eminem,
like a terrible amount of Eminem.
- So you sound like a tough
American when you talk.
- It was like Detroit.
Had like a big sort of thing to it.
And I still love that man so much.
- Yeah.
- I feel like more and more
I have to thank him so much,
you know, for getting rid of it.
- Yeah, well, he's incredible.
- [Jacob] Yeah, yeah.
- I'm a huge fan as well.
- [Jacob] Yeah.
- Yeah.
I just found it interesting
to break your accent
you listened to Eminem.
- Yeah.
- You're coming into your
auditions very aggressive.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- So, what other artists do you like?
What do you listen to?
- Right now, I mean, Bon Iver is my like,
number one.
- Oh, yeah.
- Favorite thing to listen to.
The National.
I listen to a lot of
David Bowie at the moment.
- Yeah.
- But I have this thing with David Bowie.
It's like overrated,
underrated, like he's so rated.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That then you kind of go back
and you listen to the music
and you're like, oh my God.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This is, it's really good.
- It's so artistic.
- And it sounds silly though to say like,
"David Bowie's really
good at doing music."
- Yes, but no, but you're kind of right.
You hit something there
because people know his name
and people like, I was introduced
to David Bowie from "The Labyrinth."
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, it's the coolest thing ever.
- Huge Labyrinth fan.
- That's amazing.
- That's how I got to know him.
But I knew his name more
than I knew his music.
And then when I got into music,
I just started really delving
into like his catalog.
And I get what you're saying.
He's got an incredible catalog.
- He's like an artist
just across everything.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Visual.
- Yeah, everything.
Do you collect records?
I collect vinyl.
I've way too much.
- Right, yeah.
I hear that you actually know about it.
- It's stupid, yeah.
- I don't know anything about it.
- Vinyl?
- No, like, I have a lot of them.
- Oh.
- But I'll like, I'll
go to like, a Goodwill
and just buy a random ballet
jazz thing or something.
- Fine.
- And then you listen to
it and you find stuff.
- But it's kind of an interesting way
to find music again.
- Yeah, you find stuff
that you would never,
you probably can't even find
on Spotify and stuff like that.
- Yeah, like, that's a way
I found Ann Peebles, who,
do you remember the Missy Elliott song?
You're way too young, but like there.
♪ I can't stand the rain ♪
That song, like whatever.
But so, Ann Peebles is
the original singer.
I didn't even know it was like sampled.
- [Jacob] Right, right, right.
- I didn't even know.
- That's what you find.
You find all these.
There's so many Kanye West ones
that you find, like hidden.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- Like so many.
- Sample king, yeah.
- There's so many, so many references.
And then, Bon Iver, same thing.
It's really incredible.